[موسيقى]
أطباق سهلة الأكل حتى لمن يديرون Domepu
أريد الأشخاص الذين لا يجيدون مخلفاتها أن يأكلوها
أنا مريض
الفودو
اهتزاز المسار إلى هذه الصورة باستخدام
سنتوري
[موسيقى]
اسمي هيروشي كوباياشي وأنا Zhengzhou Fujino ، مدينة سينداي ، طوكيو.
تخصص Ichifuji منتجات جديدة مستعملة
طبق فضلات
يسمى المخلفات القلب والكبد والطحال والبنكرياس.
يوجد 4 معدة
أعتقد أن أهم شيء يجب فعله عند تناول طعام لذيذ هو استخدام الأصباغ.
إيمو 2 هو الزيت نفسه
الدهون الحشوية
انها الروائح الطيبة
أطباق فضلاتها هي في الأساس أطباق مطهية
أيضًا ، الفخار هو السائد ، لكن لم يكن لدي طبق يستخدم خصائص هذا الجزء على أفضل وجه.
كنت أرغب في الاستفادة من ذلك والتعبير عنه.
[موسيقى]
همم
نظرًا لاختلاف الصلابة لكل جزء ، فإن لحم البقر الياباني فقط هو الذي يحتوي على دهون.
إنها مثل الدجاجة الصلبة. رقم 8
برائحة فريدة
طعمها مثل الزيت
الضمان نفسه هو في الأصل جزء صعب ، ولكنه يستغرق أيضًا ساعة لينضج لفترة ثم يخبز.
لأنه كذلك ، يتم إحضار طعم الدهون اللذيذ إلى المقدمة
يتوفر حوالي 12 عنصرًا أو 14 عنصرًا في عدد المدارس.
يتغير جزء الجسم حسب اليوم ، لكنه يتراوح بين الوزن و 16
إينوماتو بيكو هاهي
سحر مدينة أودا 8 طوال الوقت
إنها وجبة ممطرة لزهور الاغتصاب.
بدأ تشي يأكل 8 لحوم في الخارج
أعتقد ، لكن في الأصل لدي أسنان مزدوجة ، لذلك أفضل أكل الأعضاء الداخلية
لا بد أنها كانت من آكلات اللحوم ، لذا تفرخ أنثى
بعد كل شيء ، وجهة نظر فهم أن هناك تغذية مثل هذه الصيانة.
لأن أحدهم قرر ذلك في مكان ما
تقريبا كل الخضر التي أكلتها لها نفس القيمة
أشعر بسعادة بالغة عندما يقول الناس إنها كانت ممتعة أكثر من كونها لذيذة.
عبر عن كلا الصوتين باستخدام المخلفات واجعلهم يمارس الجنس مع أكله
اتمنى ان تكون سعيدا
[موسيقى]